excelente trabajo completando el
tutorial anterior tanto el director como
el productor están muy contentos contigo
algunas veces nuestros directores
cambian de opinión cuando ven sus
dibujos convertidos en gráficos 3d bueno
de hecho nuestros directores cambian de
opinión un montón y siempre tenemos que
ser capaces de adaptarnos a esos cambios
digamos que tenemos un director que
quiere un robot con dos cabezas pero
cada cabeza tiene que ser diferente
o sea que el director no quiere un robot
con dos copias de la misma cabeza ahora
un robot consiste en dos cabezas un
cuerpo y brazos nos gustaría saber
cuántos de esos robots podemos tener si
tenemos h cabezas de cuerpos y brazos
vimos que podemos utilizar el diagrama
de árbol para multiplicar el número de
cada tipo de parte y así tenemos el
número total de combinaciones bueno pues
tenemos h opciones para la primera
cabeza pero como la segunda cabeza tiene
que ser diferente
únicamente tenemos h menos 1 opciones
para la segunda cabeza de la misma forma
que antes tenemos de opciones para los
cuerpos y opciones para los brazos que
nos da un total de h por h menos 1 por b
por a combinaciones así es que lo único
que tenemos que hacer es multiplicar las
opciones que tenemos en cada una de las
partes los matemáticos inventan palabras
para todo
le llaman combinatoria a esta forma de
hacer cuentas en el próximo ejercicio
vas a poder practicar con otro tipo de
combinaciones